j'accueille Danny
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
boun
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel succès c'est dingue je je savais
pas qu'il y avait une N qui était
là ça fait
plaisir a ce soir il y a mi qui est venu
y V attends quand on voit la carrière de
mium mIW ça va ça na pas empêché de
faire une carrière ouais j'ai connu un
pioupou qui a pas fait
carrière carère carrière ça va et il y a
elle ça va bien elle va bien elle est là
oui oui oui oui elle va bien elle va
très bien bon ben lu demander on appelle
y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
y
ça veut pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
venir alors c'est un invité mystère tu
vas poser des questions te répond par
oui et par non tu dois deviner qui c'est
alors vas-y c'est est-ce que tu vra je
me cachais bah oui bah oui tu caché
assez mal
apparemment bon ce qu'on va faire c'est
on va égaliser un peu et on va
désépaissir on va retirer des volumes
Florence on va raccourcir
également B numéro 8 tuas tu as du
boulot ce soirou et j'avais une question
on est sur quelle chaîne là tour là on
est sur la de encore toujours la de
toujours la
de
résiste
ça passe
bien tout
superès on s'en
sortèreison la dernière fois qu'onç
cétait converti au judaïme pour vous
changé onelle
maintenant alors tu restes debout toi
non tu es assis là quelle
observation le sensité visuelle
incroyable
la viteite et ça c'est quoi après aprpr
tuas une fiche là-dessus tu as une
fiche bon Danis vous êtes ici pour un
film déjà vous êtes ici bravo
dan avec ma femme avec votre femme c'est
normal elle est tellement
mignonneiter moi B oui al vous êtes ici
pour un film dont vous êtes scénariste
réalisateur coproducteur acteur si ça se
PL pas demander à qui à qui la faute
hein sur les conseils de Laurent baffi
j'ai fait mon mon prier conseils
avisés alors ce film s'appelle la maison
du bonheur c'est l'adaptation de de
votre pièce la vie de chantier le titre
a été choisi par Yael qui ne connaissait
pas la chanson de Francis ladan sinon
vous auriez pas pris titre non
elle non non elle non ouais j'ai ah
comme la chanson de Francis LAN elle m'a
fait francan le supporterur d'équipe de
France voilà exactement qu'est-ce que tu
arrêteur ça l'énerve elle é inscrite au
générique du film oui oui fait elle
a travaillé sur le film elle a travaillé
sur le film vous avez déclaré elle a été
mon miroir sur toutes les phases de de
l'écriture elle a visionné les rush elle
a suivi le montage tout ça en s'occupant
du moufl en plus non il j'ai fait ce que
je trouvais oui oui et il est né
d'ailleurs le même jour que que Yael il
est né le même jour à 2h ça c'est les
Juifs c'est pour un gâteau pour
deut c'est l'économie c'est mais c'est
marrant Dani sérieusement à quel point
les femmes de votre vie ont toujours été
mêlé à votre travail comment ça se fait
mais j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec
tiierry Jie et
euh on a très on n pas vécu tellement
longtemps ensemble non on s'est pas
marié déjà non on n pas réussi à avoir
d'enfant non et voilà non mais Judit
gbrh déjà était très impliquée dans
votre vie professionnelle oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai moi je me un J jeis voir un
spectacle de vous elle s assise à côté
de moi pour voir quand je riais si je
riais c'est vrai ouais non mais très pro
he ouais non mais pourquoi vous
vous êtes si impliqué avec vos vos
femmes dans le travail ah je suis pas
impliqué avec mes femmes c'est c'est
plus c'est c'est pas c'est pas d'abord
c'est pas une histoire de femme c'est
une histoire de rencontre donc il se
trouve que effectivement il y a elle que
j'ai donc enlevé de Suisse puisquelle
est elle elle est suissaise euh voilà
elle elle a quitté son
travail il se trouve qu'elle a qu'elle a
des des dons pas mal de dons et voilà et
puis elle on travaille ensemble
effectivement elle a fait donc sur la
pièce elle a elle a coaché zinine solem
pour l'accent portugais elle a fait les
chorégraphies parce qu'elle a fait de la
danse elle a fait toutes les
chorégraphies de mon spectacle elle a
chanté sur des chansons de mon spectacle
alors la maison du bonheur donc de Dani
boun avec Michel larog Daniel prévau
Zinedine soilem laurent Gamelon line
Renault et vous bien sûr sorti le 7 juin
alors le pach c'est un mari radin qui
décide d'être enfin généreux ça me va
bien les cheveux ou
pas ça te plaît comme ça dan ouis
beaucoup alors le pitch donc c'est
l'histoire d'un d'un Marie radin qui
décide d'être enfin généreux avec sa
femme en lui offrant une maison de
campagne mais pour faire des économies
il fait confiance à un agent immobilier
douteux euh qui lui propose des ouvriers
foireux voilà et la surprise se
transforme en cauchemar et ça se termine
en pur délire vraiment c'est une
catastrophe quoi et c'est très drôle ben
merci ouais